good morning John so I went to France
last week where I was presenting at a
ridiculously fancy advertising industry
convention and I spent most of my week
alternating between just being
tremendously satisfied at how pleasant
everything was and being powerfully
disturbed by ostentatious displays of
wealth a friend of mine had a friend who
had a yacht and they were like you
should come and see this yacht and I was
like dude I've seen boats before and
they were like no this is not a boat and
so I went and indeed upon arrival on the
boat I immediately wanted to see the
engine room in the water treatment and
desalination systems the yacht was very
cool and very pretty
it has a crew of 12 people who live and
work on the yacht and there's a 24-hour
diner and it costs two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to fill up the gas tank
of the yacht seems like a nice place to
have a party so as far as thoughts from
places places go the South of France is
a place that is very easy to have some
thoughts from haha none of the main
goals of advertising is to create need
where no need exists and I had a hard
time not thinking about that as I
wandered around and was constantly
besieged by an AT&T AdWords campaign
that excitedly implied the
unquestionable benefit of more in a
place that rich people spend lots of
money to go to so they can spend lots of
money at fancy shops and restaurants
manufactured discontent is both
everywhere and invisible the thing is
hitting my toes you gotta insulate
better this is a place where people go
to realize how much they don't have even
if you can't afford to spend 2,000 euro
on a jacket there's a store right around
the corner with a 9000 euro jacket even
if you can afford a really big boat
there's a bigger boat next door and
particularly at this event not only is
there always something you can't afford
but there's always a better party with
cooler people that you're not invited to
I was surprised not that I was a little
upset by all of this but why I was a
little upset it wasn't just because of
the tremendous difference that this
wealth could make in the lives of people
who are suffering but also because the
monstrous displays of wealth I saw
seemed to come from sad places like
mostly from personal insecurities people
want other people to know that they are
important and that they matter and that
they're powerful and cool John we're
headed into a world of such tremendous
productivity that there is hope in me
that
someday we will have so many resources
that everyone will be able to minimize
their suffering but when I see that new
world taking shape in places like Canon
San Tropez I worried that no one will
ever be satisfied with what they have
and so wealth will never stop
concentrating and we won't be able to
turn our surpluses to truly global goals
like ridding ourselves of poverty and
war and the global insecurities caused
by climate change of course at the same
time all around I saw families who loved
each other and were enjoying the beauty
and wonder of this absolutely gorgeous
and historically fascinating place it
reminds me that many of the smartest
people in the world aren't famous there
are people who are smart enough to
realize that real happiness doesn't come
from being the biggest fish with the
most people tripping over themselves to
be like them it comes from being
personally secure in yourself and your
life and your values and your future
that has something to do with money but
definitely not everything it also has to
do with being comfortable with the life
and the identity that you've created for
yourself and doing things you love with
people you love hi Catherine
what Mediterranean méditerranée out
méditerranée outs
[Applause]
congratulations John I'll see you on
Tuesday
what are you most afraid of whole world
looking like Tashi are also the infinite
how are you doing baby too much Frank oh
man this is not any snapchat hey you
know sometimes it's a good just take a
picture hi guys